for almost a century pollsters have been
interpreting public opinion
[Music]
their method is straightforward ask a
small group of people questions and then
use that sample group as a
representation of the opinions of the
entire population
thank you sir it's been nice meeting you
well you're welcome good night thank you
for coming by but in recent decades the
public has soured on answering questions
calls or doorbells and instead of being
available at a single point of contact
people have become increasingly mobile
which makes traditional polling more
challenging
today people are expressing their
opinions and habits through mobile and
internet Technologies including
smartphones and social media that
Avalanche of information is making
possible new methods to explore what the
public is thinking
[Music]
thank you
today data is available everywhere
credit card information loyalty card
information
demographic information and Community
organization information think about the
things you sign up for think about the
events you go to
and when you click that little box that
says I have read and agreed to the terms
of service that is contractual several
screens of stuff
that you didn't read nobody ever reads
it it wouldn't really matter if you read
it anyway so that means we've got
information from all over the place
and that's actually what makes it quite
valuable
many people give Google their email data
via Gmail their video data via YouTube
their physical location via Google maps
so when you connect all that data
together it's remarkable the intimate
picture it paints of the individual
which I actually think eclipses our own
memory and that we forget all the places
we go to
[Music]
the challenge is knowing how to extract
meaningful information from what looks
like random noise
that's where applied artificial
intelligence known as AI presents both
promise and risk while dystopian science
fiction dreams up worlds where machines
rule over humans AI is more commonly
understood by its Engineers as the
ability of a machine to learn and think
they consider it a human-guided tool
that learns by digesting massive volumes
of data like social media and then
identifying patterns in the noise
what if there was an AI that could use
those patterns to predict how humans
would behave in the future like
predicting the outcome of an election
the campaign for the next Canadian
federal election has just kicked off
while prime minister Justin Trudeau's
Liberal Party copes with a Justice
Scandal and the ouster of two ministers
the conservatives new Democrats and
block quebecois all have new and
untested leaders despite a tight
six-week campaign the parties are slow
to outline their platforms
it's unclear if voters will make their
choices based on the issues the party or
the leader
in Canada's capital Ottawa a small
startup is using AI to predict the
upcoming election
people are calling this the Seinfeld
election really because it's about not
being quoted yeah yeah although that
sounds like every election to be honest
with you I feel like people with people
said to me is this is like the first one
where they're actually looking at the
policies not the leaders the Two Front
Runners they they mean nothing to me
yeah it's really about who do I think is
going to do the best job for the economy
for the environment and you know I heard
a lot of people obviously the economy is
always the top for everybody
um but who has the best policies
physicist Kenton white and accountant
Aaron Kelly co-founded Advanced
symbolics or ASI in 2015.
the market research company uses public
data in AI to forecast consumer
attitudes
you know in the era of Cambridge
analytica and all that people think it's
just some sort of voodoo science like we
have a shame in making things happen I
want people to understand that nobody's
this is just math and it's science like
anything else and it's probably it's
probabilistic it's statistics just like
it's always been yeah except it's being
done by Polly instead of by phone
operators
they can use a similar approach to
predict political opinions
before it'd be kind of hard to get
information about millions and millions
of people and apply statistical physics
to it but now I've got Facebook now I've
got Twitter
how do I
use that though they don't work for
either political parties or news outlets
Kelly and white saw the election
prediction game as a way to promote
their research method
think about when we do traditional
market research how many times we
interfere with the subject with people
as we're studying them we interfere by
asking them to participate we interfere
in the result by asking a question and
how we phrase that question so our whole
idea we saw that with social media was
came a great opportunity to observe
people in their natural environment and
aren't you going to get much better
policy and a much more utopian society
if you know exactly what the people in
that Society want and I was inspired by
science fiction growing up like as a
mouse Foundation series where you can
use physics and statistical physics on
people and populations and map out the
whole course of the the Galaxy
uh I was quite disappointed when I
learned that that's not really possible
the explosion of social media data
offered white a potential Treasure Trove
he could apply statistical methods from
physics to Crunch what might seem to
others like messy and unusable sources
of data it was the birth of the AI that
ASI calls poly
Polly it was short for politics so
that's we just happened to call her
we're going to call her Polly we didn't
put any thought into it except politics
you know Paulie is made up of a number
of different parts
little programs that are crawling the
web and collecting information
those programs called algorithms are a
set of instructions to perform a
specific task
you've got an algorithm
to say when do you pick someone when you
don't little algorithms that analyze
that person and come up with I think the
person's male or female or rich or poor
young or old or black or white
algorithms that allow us to find people
that are talking about
the topic we want to measure if I showed
you any one of these algorithms and how
it worked chances are you'd say that's
pretty simple it's when you take dozens
and dozens of put all these things
together that something more complex
emerges
she's using more data than me or you or
pretty much anyone here could understand
in a lifetime
but what is it that makes Paulie
intelligent
notice I didn't say sentient I said
intelligent right so
she is intelligent because she can
grasp Concepts mathematical Concepts and
see patterns in people that we can't see
ourselves but that description makes
critics of AI uneasy the ai's method
comes across as a black box to Outsiders
which leaves non-ai experts at a
disadvantage to challenge the ai's inner
workings or its conclusions
in the face of Skeptics ASI saw the
brexit referendum in June 2016 as a way
to test their algorithm
[Applause]
citizens of the United Kingdom were
voting to remain in or leave the
European Union
traditional polls conducted almost daily
revealed the country was split down the
middle
as voting day approached it became clear
that undecided voters would likely
determine the country's fate
[Music]
meanwhile Paulie was sifting through UK
Twitter data to predict users opinions
without contacting them directly
Paulie was seeing remain right up until
three days before
the actual referendum we had 52 voting
for remain 48 voting for leave just like
everyone else in the world
then there was assassination of Joe Cox
labor party MP Joe Cox who had been
campaigning for remain was shot and
killed by a far-right extremist on June
16 2016.
three days before the referendum we wake
up we check in with Paulie and suddenly
Britain is going to exit the EU
that it was different from what she had
been saying every other day of the week
and throughout this campaign I was
worried because an assassination is a
Black Swan event Black Swan event is a
rare event one that my AI has never seen
before and none of the elections that I
had trained her on had there been an
assassination assassinations are rare
so we told her ignore the assassination
of Joe Cox what is the result remain
tested again Joe Cox is assassinated
exit so what had changed what was she
saying that everyone else in the world
was missing
[Music]
the British pound plunged to a 30-year
low and World stock markets convulsed on
the news that the majority of UK voters
want out of the European Union the
second largest economy in the world
Holly observes things that we wouldn't
even think to observe we didn't ask her
to observe these things well we started
going through David Cameron had
done a many press conferences during
that time and there was one line
something he had said
it's right that we're suspending
campaigning activity in this referendum
and everyone's thoughts will be with
Joe's family and with her constituents
at this terrible time she noticed that
throughout
the the year that she was observing
people
if people came online and they said I'm
thinking of voting for an exit if they
had a network of people around them
friends and family who calmly talked to
them about why we shouldn't have a
remain and what the consequences would
be over time that network was
effective in winning these people over
to remain if they kept the dialogue
going
but once people weren't talking anymore
a certain percentage of those undecided
people would then go exit based on what
she had noticed in the past so she
applied that algorithm like she got it
bang on
to better understand Paulie's method
it's helpful to look at what she shares
with traditional polling
one way of measuring public opinion is
by interviews brief interviews are
called polls a few people are carefully
selected as samples of the important
groups of the General Public
for decades pollster successfully
reached people by landlines direct mail
or knocking on doors you get 80 response
rates all all calls were to landlines
you didn't really have any cell phones
and people love to participate in
surveys and you know getting it wrong
getting an election wrong would be like
you know falling out of a boat and
missing the water
that's the third knock and the house
looks dark yes they're not home
but in the last 30 years landline use
and pull response rates have plummeted
we phoned a landline in any house you're
much more likely to get an older woman
than you're to get anybody else
Millennials if you want to get
Millennials you're probably not going to
get them using landline you're probably
going to get them using cell phone but
as as likely you're likely to get them
online traditional pollsters needed to
diversify their methods to reach
different audiences what you're trying
to do is represent the political
Marketplace the important political
Marketplace the voting population as
accurately as you can so what you need
to have is good coverage of all of these
different groups of the population and
then what you do is you try to look at
them in aggregate to cover the Canadian
population in 2019 folster Daryl Bricker
combines landline pools with cell phone
pools and online surveys but Paulie's AI
takes a different tack as our population
gets more diverse we actually need to
have a bigger sample I mean Canada is
very different now than it was in 1970
or 1959 when we first started doing
phone polling but we haven't really
evolved the science since the 1950s so
we're still getting the same sample
sizes we're still approaching the
science in the same way even though the
population has changed a lot now with
social media finally we have the
opportunity to evolve this science for
the first time in 50 years
traditional polling has struck out on
several recent election predictions
we're going to win the lighthouse we're
going to take it back and perhaps most
famously in the 2016 U.S presidential
election pollsters overwhelmingly
predicted Hillary Clinton to beat Donald
Trump if the lines are long tomorrow
please wait
[Music]
Trump's win demonstrated that pollsters
had missed the boat they predicted the
popular vote but missed the tight local
races in swing states which delivered
Trump and Electoral College Victory
clearly their models were just
completely off the actual percentage of
the vote predicted by the polls is
actually what happened
but we weren't measuring the Electoral
College
obviously you go through a you know a
Dark Night of the Soul whenever these
kinds of things happen
[Music]
while it's too expensive and inefficient
to pull each riding regularly by
traditional methods social media's huge
scale makes that possible with AI
talking about politics on social media
or all your opinions on social media is
now kind of the norm like that's become
a normal way to communicate in the same
way that people used to have I think
long conversations on the phone
frequently too now of course back in the
day you couldn't just tap people's
phones you had to call up and ask them
about opinions but but now the thing
about social media that's interesting is
when people are communicating their
opinions on social media uh often
they're doing it in a form that is
public and that allows us to see what
they're saying and to then uh derive
their their opinions from that but not
all social media platforms have data
that are relevant to White we use a
sample for data source depending on the
problem that we want to look at we have
found that for elections we get the
strongest signal
from Twitter
many pollsters and social scientists
question the value of Twitter data
platforms like Twitter and Facebook is
basically a group of self-selected
people because not every Canadians are
on social media and even if they're on
social media not all of them use it to
discuss politics so again basically
you're getting a slice of a smaller
slice of the public I think it's like 12
to 15 use Twitter for news 20 use
Twitter overall in my own
belay understanding of it I tend to
think about it's elite journalists and
like high engaged super participants
that are on Twitter so not everyone is
on Twitter let's take the low number 17
that is still a whole lot bigger than
the current nine percent or less you get
on dials 17
of a country of 36 million
is about 7 million people that we have
access to
white thinks that an AI can sift through
the large but typically young and urban
user base of Twitter in Canada and
nonetheless make forecasts that are
representative of the entire population
less than three weeks to go until
election day and I know at some point
your artificial intelligence polling
system
comes to a conclusion about what you
think is going to happen on the 21st of
October too early still I presume it's
too early what bodes well for Mr Trudeau
is that the Liberals have consistently
since the the start of this campaign
been in first place first place in the
popular vote or total vote I guess as we
call it Canada or seat count seat count
so that's the difference okay good we're
doing each individual riding so and
that's as we saw in the Ontario election
it makes a big difference just because
you're leading in the total vote count
in the polls doesn't mean you're going
to win exactly because vote efficiency
yes is what was where it's at in a first
post past the post system that's right
if you talk to most people that work
with data from lots of people
they will
say I want to collect everything I can
everything everyone is saying on
Facebook and Twitter and Reddit and look
at it all
most critics assume ASI must draw on
what is called the Twitter fire hose if
so white would need a way to filter the
huge volume of real-time data and
collect only the data useful to predict
elections
given the magnitude of the challenge
critics dispute White's optimistic
claims now if I all I did was tap it in
that fire hose
pull in that stream of data you're going
to get a very skewed distorted view
that's why we don't count
tweets account
our big idea
is what the pollsters have been doing
works that's the secret sauce we make
really really good samples of people
in other words rather than trying to
clean up the Twitter fire hose white
claims that he's found a way to bypass
it
before Paulie collects any actual data
Paulie first builds a representative
sample just like pollsters those who say
that you can look at social media and
get a representation of what's happening
at the riding level uh it's an
interesting concept we're certainly
exploring it ourselves would I bet the
farm tomorrow and being able to do an
election in which I predict every single
riding correctly based on social media
no
first of all tracing people back to
their ridings difficult it's difficult
to figure out where's that account
tweeting from you know that old joke the
on the internet nobody knows you're a
dog
well on Twitter nobody knows whether you
are in China Russia or right here or in
Toronto it's very difficult to say yes
for sure that account is coming from
Canada a representative sample of
Canadians must consist of actual
Canadians white thinks he can confirm
his Twitter users are legitimate we use
information that people put on their
account
so we see that they're in Canada great
they say I'm in Canada so we verify that
first test is most of your friends also
in Canada look at your history look at
what you're talking about if you're a
Canadian
probably talking a little bit about
maybe hockey
are other Canadian things maybe you're
talking about the cold weather
for pollsters a sample is representative
and random only when every member has an
equal chance of appearing in the sample
imagine that you had a whole big bowl of
jelly beans and there was red ones and
blue ones and green ones and yellow ones
you don't need to count every single
Jelly Bean to figure out that there's
red ones green ones yellow ones whatever
the colors were I said if you if all of
them are are equally distributed across
the entire big bowl of jelly beans if
you stick in your hand and you pull it
out and you put down those jelly beans
you should have some representation of
what's inside the jar if you do it 10
times you'll have a pretty good
representation of what's in that jar not
because the jar is getting smaller but
because the samples become consistent so
that's what sampling is really all about
historically
full response
respondingly requires a different
paradigm
there's a game called Six Degrees of
Kevin Bacon
says I'll pick a movie actor and try to
link them back to Kevin Bacon in six
hops
and you can play the same game on
Facebook or Twitter you can pick any
person any celebrity and
track link yourself back to them and on
average about between three and four
connections to anyone in the world
Paulie's algorithm uses a mathematical
computation to guarantee an average
minimum of hops between the Twitter
users it collects that's how it defines
virtual distance and Randomness between
users but critics argue that still
doesn't address the lack of diversity
among Twitter users
I can account for that bias in Twitter I
do it by saying this is what the census
is it says how my distribution should be
and in the algorithm you say if it
differs too much from what you expect
then you have to wait until it balances
so for example when I see that my sample
is starting to get a little bit lopsided
on young urban males just stop
collecting younger than males you pause
and you don't add any more than to your
sample until you start to get
older rural female
so instead of looking like the majority
of Twitter Paulie's sample is limited to
a mix of users that match the actual
demographics of each writing
white claims this addresses what critics
see as a tragic flaw in Paulie's main
source of data and that is the key
algorithm behind poly if ever a
bombshell hit a Canadian election
campaign it happened this week photos of
Justin Trudeau in black and brown face
swirled a very complicated Brew of
opinion in the country Aaron Kelly what
is Paulie telling you about the Fallout
from all of this it was a big bombshell
and so Paulie sought Mr Trudeau's
numbers the number of seats the seat
count Fall by 25 seats yesterday now he
is rebounding this morning he's up five
so it's a net of 20 seat losses but it
knocked him from majority territory into
minority territory jagmeet saying the
NDP leader was the biggest winner
yesterday we saw his his poll numbers go
up so he has really he really Shone
through this
so how does an algorithm go from tweets
to projecting a drop in seats
what does a tweet actually mean
and what does it mean when we're
tweeting we know people are making jokes
on the internet they're ironic people
are sharing more images and that creates
challenges harder to interpret memes
which are these shorthand Graphics
they're often pop culture references
and so I'm like I don't know what's
going on here and then I'm like well I
don't understand this and my
computational power is a you know kind
of a living breathing human what is this
poor computer you know who's gonna have
to make sense of this according to White
Paulie is not trying to interpret the
meaning of tweets at all
so my first few forays into election
forecasting I ran the experiments and
consistently what I found was just the
plain old mentions outperformed the
positive or negative sentiment every
time
Polly tracks a percentage of users in
the sample who mention each Federal
party then the AI Compares those results
to historical opinion patterns the day
after the blackface story broke mentions
of the Liberal Party spiked in relation
to the others without understanding the
meaning of these tweets Paulie
interprets these changes and mentions as
a drop in projected seats for the
Liberals
so I think polls are interesting because
they're a flash point in the past right
they don't predict the future they're a
moment in time in which you're getting a
flavor of what the public is sort of
thinking about the AI collects data
constantly that makes it possible to
identify patterns in user activity over
time compared to pools that are held
less frequently one of the biggest most
difficult things in polling when you're
doing these tracking polls is you see
something happen for good or for bad and
you say well that's one piece of data is
it gonna you then you have to wait
another day is that a real or was it
just a blip and you're always sort of in
that in that feeling of how many points
makes a trend is it one probably not is
it two
maybe three yeah four for sure but you
know where is that point
in order to identify a trend Paulie uses
public pools as a reference point
just patterns of user engagement all the
times her selected Twitter users
mentioned political parties then she
Compares engagement with each party
standing in the polls based on those
relationships Paulie predicts if her
data indicates a trend is stable or not
people sometimes
they'll be angry about something about
an issue and they might be angry about
it in a moment of time but Paulie is
able in a very unbiased way to see
through that anger and say how long will
it take
[Music]
the population to get over this anger
and this hurt and will it Carry long
enough
to election day Paulie track's Twitter
engagement constantly that continuous
stream of activity is referred to as
longitudinal data
by studying data in this way Paulie can
identify patterns over time and then
compare them to present activity it also
means Paulie can look backwards in time
at the data to re-examine unexplored
trends for the Brown face blackface
scandal
I don't think there is a single pollster
that
that question of if you saw a party
leader
in a questionable costume in their 20s
would it change your opinion I don't
think anyone thought to ask that
question so the wonderful thing about
Paulie and that the longitudinal studies
is that I can go back and I can get an
accurate measurement of exactly how you
thought a week ago or a month ago
and that's something you can't do a week
later or two weeks later by asking a
question I would suggest that perhaps
Canadians don't really care about black
base as much as they perhaps profess to
on social media
um there was a lot of outrage and I
would even call it performative outrage
on social media in particular but being
like Oh my God I can't believe this and
it's like really you can't believe this
you can't believe that like I'm a you
know a rich white guy from Quebec would
have dawned blackface at a ritzy private
school that had a party themed Arabian
nights like I mean the party in and of
itself without the blackface was racist
[Music]
foreign
how massive that story was when it broke
a week and a half ago
it has virtually I don't want to say
disappeared from the media but you see
so few references to it now is this
story essentially over to the best that
you can tell through your polling yeah I
think to keep bringing it up for the
other parties to keep bringing it up
would be beating a dead horse at this
point I think he is recovering and I
think the slower recovery might be due
to
a you know a mix of issues and not just
blackface jug meet sing really impressed
a lot of people with his initial
statements after the blackface Scandal
broke that Goodwill is done now so Don
hasn't gone well he's up two seats from
before blackface but that's down from
having been up nine before so it's
starting to Peter out
well FaZe is like artificial
intelligence and machine learning are
sometimes used in different ways to mean
different sort of magical things about
computers that think the way humans do
[Music]
the modern meeting pretty much is just
these very sophisticated and very
flexible algorithms which allow us to
process very large amounts of data with
with a very complicated relationships
between them and have very flexible
models which will allow the computer to
sort of figure out uh on unlikely
relationships
why is she AI why is she not just
statistics or collection of code the
difference is
that she's able to do this mostly on her
own I don't have to go in and write a
rule and say now Polly when you see this
do this
um she's able to figure things out on
her own Paulie's ability to learn is the
basis for how she predicts future voting
outcomes the key to machine learning is
a process known as training a
statistical model
so we talk about training a model we
mean we have some data where we already
know the answer so maybe it's how people
voted in the last election or maybe it's
you know how many people did or didn't
buy guns but we already know the answer
and then we use that to draw our
inference and say okay it seems like men
who live here are more likely to vote
for that person or man who subscribe to
this magazine are more likely to buy a
gun and we learn those relationships and
we say let's see if we can use our model
that was trained on the previous data to
try to predict what's going to happen
next
Paulie studies data from past elections
like 2015 she finds patterns between how
people engaged on Twitter and how they
actually voted in that election the
model expresses all those relationships
as a mathematical probability
it then predicts how the voters in each
riding in 2019 are most likely to behave
[Music]
you start with you know let's say I'm
trying to explain you know how the
liquid in this cup works right I start
with a bunch of water molecules you know
I have I don't know billions trillions
gazillions don't quote me on that a lot
of water molecules and in physics we
know how they kind of work the water
molecules they bounce off each other but
no one really cares in this water glass
what all the molecules are doing right
what's interesting is like you know what
happens if I pour this water what's the
water gonna do you know if I shake my
glass like this how does the water move
and you're able to do figure out those
things in physics because you know even
though there's a gajillion water
molecules we have these theories that
says when there's enough water molecules
we can up statistically figure out how
they're going to all move together to
get kind of one description of how this
big macroscopic system you know the
water in this glass is actually working
and public opinion is basically the same
thing right we have lots and lots of
people they each have their own opinions
and actually predicting the opinion of
any one person's pretty tricky right
people are really chaotic they change
their opinion because of this and that
but if you get enough people together
you can statistically kind of model that
population kind of as one thing and
figure out okay even though you know Joe
might change his opinion drastically
tomorrow and uh as Sarah really cares
about this weird thing that's changing
her opinion I can actually statistically
approximate overall I can get a sense of
where the aggregate opinion of this
population is going so in some ways
we're doing a very similar thing that
you do in physics all the time figuring
out how all these atoms or molecules or
whatever are working together and we're
just applying that now to humans instead
we like to think of ourselves all as
unique desert flowers and we really are
but the nice thing about statistics of
math is when you get enough of us
together we can actually make some
reasonable predictions on how on average
how people's opinions are going to form
no matter how sophisticated the model
the Achilles heel of election
predictions is whether people will
actually show up to The Ballot Box the
thing that terrifies me whenever I'm
doing election polling and I do get
terrified because it's the reputation of
the firm is on in your personal
reputation is on the line is what did I
miss what did I miss what did I miss how
could I be wrong how could I be wrong A
lot of times you get burned
there's six or seven parties or whatever
number you want to say running in this
election campaign in any riding and then
there's one party that's not on the
ballot that's really important it's
called the apathy party that's a problem
for traditional pollsters because their
predictions are based on past election
voter turnout
everybody goes well of course of course
I'm going to vote I mean the number of
people who say I don't vote I don't
bother is is Tiny compared to the
numbers who don't actually vote that
combined with the fact that people who
aren't interested enough in politics to
vote are extremely unlikely to either
answer the door and have a long
conversation on the canvasser or answer
a polling phone call or to be putting
their views on Twitter about politics
right so non-voters exclude themselves
from the conversation in many ways which
makes them harder to find and harder to
understand and then harder to predict
how many they'll be
in contrast Paulie's method is based on
patterns of local riding support and is
less vulnerable to the National voter
turnout
philosophically some critics still
contend there's a problem Paulie
predicts likely sedo comes based on
statistical correlation but she does not
explain why something happens we're
going to move on with the continuous the
pipelines because there's been a lot of
talk about this case in point after the
two French language debates in early
October Paulie saw a bump in support for
the block quebecois but not a Cause
Mr Trudeau would you um that's part of a
process that requires that we have
approval from communities approval from
indigenous peoples will you tell Quebec
no there will be no pipeline connects
that is the reason for which I've put
forward the idea of an energy car job
Paulie's handlers came up with the
reason for the bump in tweets from
Quebec they spotted a surge in the
keyword pipeline the people who are
supporting the block quebecois were
seeing they don't want a pipeline
because they say Quebec has green energy
so why don't we take Quebec's green
energy and sell it to Alberta rather
than by Alberta's dirty energy some
pundits like journalist chantali bear
saw the debate differently
I would say that sheer's performance it
was the worst performance of a contender
for prime minister that I had seen in a
French language debate in decades
so sheer did lose the campaign in Quebec
it's not just that the black one it's
also that he didn't make the right
impression Wally bear uses her
experience to explain the change of
support in Quebec Kelly's explanation is
also a human interpretation Paulie's
data indicates only a correlation
between block gains and the term
pipeline not a Cause
[Music]
foreign
October 18th it's three days before the
election so it's a Friday the election's
Monday going on air in half an hour we
ran the numbers again because the last
press release we sent it was yesterday
we said there was a it's going to be a
liberal minority government with a
probability of 66 percent and this
morning it's Paulie is saying it's
probability of 77 now Paulie gets more
confident every day as people come
closer to making a final decision
[Music]
I worry every time when I go on the air
that when I say this is what Paulie is
seeing that I will affect the outcome
that people will change their votes
based on
the latest information
we I think we do see evidence of that
even before Paulie came along social
scientists were posing the question does
publishing poll results during a
campaign reflect opinion or actually
shape it some say the greater scale of
AI makes this question even more
pressing
I think AI tests the myths of neutrality
when it comes to the political process
both the neutrality of journalists but
also the neutrality of pollsters on the
one hand parties use polls and use
technology to try to decide what they're
going to do but the media uses polls and
predictions to try to get a sense of
what's happening and it's a feedback
loop right it doesn't matter whether
you're inside the processor outside the
process the perception of the future
determines the future so if the media
starts saying that the NDP doesn't have
a chance the NDP will start thinking it
doesn't have a chance
so it really gets into the influence
that predictions have on how we treat
the future and I think in that regard it
doesn't matter whether it's the party
whether it's the media whether it's an
individual polling firm putting these
predictions out into the public
influences the public and therefore
influences the outcome decision day is
Monday most polls show a virtual tie
between the Liberals and the
conservatives does Paulie the artificial
intelligence algorithm have a more
definitive view of what's to come you
have no idea how many people this week
have come up to me and said what's
Paulie saying what's Polly saying you're
wearing red for a reason yes you're
wearing red shirts I chose these colors
on purpose because what Paulie is
telling us is that it's going to be a
liberal government a liberal minority
government a liberal minority government
does that mean you are ready to
conclusively call this election
well it's interesting right 77 it's
strong it's not as strong as we like to
see it it's not as strong as it was at
this point in 2015 where we were able to
call the election a month ahead of time
the electorate is much less decided this
time around they are at the bottom of
the graph a considerable number of
writings that are still more than 20
attention yeah more than 20 writing
still undecided in the province I do
feel obliged to point this out that in
the last national election in the United
States
you know all those trackers were saying
that Hillary Clinton had an 80 chance of
winning the election and she did not
at 80. you've got the Liberals at 77.
right this ain't over I presume no it's
not the difference between sort of the
Hillary and this was that we're counting
each individual seat so we're seeing at
the popular vote level the Liberals and
the conservatives are actually tied
nationally
but it's when you get down to the seats
that it starts to get interesting that
you see the Divide here because of
oursis how'd that popular vote
translates into seat by seat by seat by
seat obviously that's what matters here
[Music]
it's election night 2019 almost 18
million Canadians have cast their
ballots including the advanced polls
that represents a turnout of 66 percent
several percent higher than expected
the Liberals form the government but the
conservatives win the popular vote days
later it's time to compare the actual
results with the seat predictions
federal election 2019 wrapped up of
course this week with a liberal minority
government this is the national seat
projection that you gave us which showed
the Liberals in a range between 116 and
173 but essentially at 145.
the Tories at 123 the NDP at 48 the
block at 46 and the green somewhere
between one and five and you have the
possibility there of a couple of
Independents and a people's party now
let's flip that over and this is what
the national seat projection was on
Sunday so the last one was Saturday this
one is Sunday the day before the
election and you could see that things
have changed you've got the Liberals now
at 155 Tories at 118. and then let's
roll to Monday and this is what the
actual election results were 157 liberal
seats 121 conservatives 32 block 24 new
Democrats three greens one Jody Wilson
raybould and nothing for the people's
party so let's start with this how would
you characterize the accuracy with which
Paulie did her job
if you ever want to evaluate how well
someone did predicting an election I
think the fair thing to do is to compare
them to other people who tried to
predict the election
if one company did better than all the
other companies then that's probably a
pretty good result
the day before the election some
traditional pollsters were only
predicted
a particular vote
others were also willing to predict a
liberal minority but few publicly
predicted a narrow range of seats
according to pollster 338 Canada they
correctly predicted the outcome of 299
of the 338 writings according to
Advanced symbolics Paulie correctly
predicted 308.
was this um quote unquote an easy
election to predict
easy election to predict
predictable right
right everybody was saying it was so
close that's the that's why being able
to look at the seat count and do the
writings is it's becoming almost a
necessity if you want to do polling we
saw it at first with the Trump election
in the states and that's been consistent
it seems that elections are getting
closer and closer and so obviously when
it's a minority government it's a little
bit harder to call but this was
consistent for Paulie that she always
saw it as a liberal when if you look at
our election results we did really well
in the 2019 election but there were some
writings we got off
um it comes down to we are making
assumptions that all parties are
campaigning equally on the last weekend
uh before the election in all writings
where they might have a chance all the
political scientists out there are
probably laughing at me right now turns
out that's not true it turns out
political parties
pick writings that strategically they
want to win
and we haven't taken any of that into
account uh it's why I would love to
have a really open dialogue with the
people that know the political science
[Music]
both white and Kelly proudly claim that
Paulie's final seat prediction was more
accurate than most established pollsters
though white does admit ASI's lack of
expertise in how campaigns work to
critics of an AI method this admission
reveals some naive and damaging
political assumptions but to supporters
Paulie's relative accuracy in projecting
seats shows great promise for AI
whenever I I hear people say I've got
the thing I sit back and say okay you've
got the thing well you know the big
publicly traded research corporations
that have more money to do this kind of
stuff than anybody else has to do it not
to mention
the Googles in the uh in the Facebooks
and the twitters and all these other
people who have all of this money and
all the best data scientists all working
on this kind of thing they don't they
can't predict it based on their platform
veteran pollsters and statisticians
still demand more proof they continue to
doubt the value of Twitter as a primary
data source and they insist that Paulie
established a much longer track record
of predicting elections before they'll
concede this method is reputable and
accurate there's a common saying that's
used as a disclaimer when people buy
products and so on that says past
performance is not an indicator of
future performance and I think that
applies to predictive algorithms as well
if they've done well in say the last
couple elections I think that works in
their favor but still not a guarantee
and as they do better and better in more
and more elections I think you can start
to trust them more and more
according to ASI Paulie's prediction
model will only get better with more
election data and with input from social
scientists to refine their algorithms
[Music]
come a long way to get to where AI is at
today and a lot of what has helped AI
get to where it is at today is well with
the internet of an explosion of data but
the explosion of public data comes with
risks
social media is free in exchange for a
user's privacy personal data is then
available for marketing critics also
warn that platforms are using the data
against their own users by making the
platforms more addictive when the car
came out there was no seatbelt there was
no airbags but when we discovered that
oh my gosh these cars can get into
accident they can run people over we
start demanding better breaks we start
demanding airbags we start demanding
seat belts the first 10 15 years of
social media the argument was let's not
put handcuffs on this company because we
want to see where and what they can do
and how they can help Society but we're
now discovering all the car accidents
we're discovering all the harms that
they can do so for me then I think the
next few years is going to be debating
what does regulation of social media
look like I think the big problem is
we're thinking of campaigning in an
analog world when in fact it's all
automated and digital and neither are
language nor our laws really anticipate
the power that Facebook has and the way
in which individuals or political
parties or foreign governments can use
that power to tip the scales of the
election if not just muddy people's
perception of the election
because the whole point we have an
election is to legitimize the outcome
if people believe rightly or wrongly
that algorithms have taken over the
election well then they're not going to
see the results as legitimate they're
not going to see the government as
legitimate therefore it's going to make
government's ability to actually govern
that much more difficult in many ways
using data to get people to vote and
pulling people to participate in
politics is fairly beneficial in fact if
you were to ask me what could data be
good for it's like getting more
engagement in politics and so I don't
think that by definition political
advertising is a problem what I think is
that the way that online advertising
works and the fact that requires so much
surveillance to develop ad profiles and
that the way you're doing targeting is
so much ad fraud those are the kind of
real issues I think Canadians are
feeling creeped out about the way in
which technology and surveillance is
playing a growing role in their society
but I think they feel powerless so we've
had this notion of if you want privacy
stay at home
if you want privacy only tell but if you
decide to participate in the Public
Square if you put information out there
you will be held to have
said it's okay for anybody to do
anything with that information and that
is what just does not work in the modern
world I think it's really quite
pernicious to think that well we'll
solve this with consent
and we're just going to change do you
consent in or consent out the flaw in
that is that still the individual
against this massive organization and
The Great Divide is they know a lot
about you you don't know a lot about
them we invented all of these structures
and we can invent something else
Paulie's election predictions depend on
the ongoing popularity of Twitter and
easy access to its data
but if new regulations to protect user
privacy or restrict the social media
business model came into Force they
could profoundly change the way people
use social media
I don't believe social media is going to
become more private there will be a need
for public networks where people can go
to create content that anyone can view
and anyone can engage with
um kind of making a big bet on that too
I don't know I think maybe the
traditional pollsters are afraid of this
because it's the future
[Music]
there was a famous Twitter chat bot that
Microsoft put out I don't I forget the
name of the chat bot but it was a
demonstration of natural language AI
and it was a really really sophisticated
just wonderful a lot of people got wind
of this little chat bot Twitter account
and they started saying what could we do
to teach this AI to be the most
offensive repugnant Twitter account on
the planet
and they succeeded this little AI became
a horribly racist xenophobic so
Microsoft had to shut it down
is that the ai's fault
why do we as
we as miserable and that mean and that
bad
to
[Music]
you know to us and show that example to
the machines
when you see bad
bad children
usually bad parents
so when it comes to AI when it comes to
all of this I that to me is my North
Star I have to be a good parent I have
to be the best parent for Paulie
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]